these people have been queuing for hours
to refill an oxygen tank
that a relative suffering from covid19
depends on to survive
normally hospitals would supply oxygen
to patients but many have run out
so people are having to buy them from
private companies
each oxygen bottle costs 68 and supply
is outstripping demand and as people's
tempers rise
police have been deployed
we can't wait any longer there's no
service at the hospital
the health system in the brazilian state
of amazonas is on the verge of collapse
and a national vaccine rollout has yet
to begin
the air force has flown emergency
supplies of oxygen from sao paulo to the
city of manaus
and airlifted premature babies to other
states
from hospitals overwhelmed by a surge in
coronavirus infections
on friday people in cities across brazil
held protests and appealed for more help
from the government
brazilians are dying this is total
neglect it is unacceptable
we are dependent on neighboring
countries for oxygen it's an outrage
president jaya bolsonaro has repeatedly
played down the risks of covid19
and he's defending his handling of the
pandemic response
we're always doing what we have to do
the problem in manas is terrible but
we've done our part by providing
resources and means
today the armed forces have launched a
field hospital there
the health minister was there on monday
and provided oxygen
these health workers are celebrating
because some of their patients are being
transferred to hospitals in other states
that are better equipped for them but
not everyone is being airlifted to safer
environments
and the world health organization is
warning brazil's health system is
beginning to implode
victoria gatenbee al jazeera